[Music]
so why is the eu
creating a digital covid certificate
well remember how hard it has been to
travel in recent months
or how we've had to quarantine after
crossing a border the eu wants to make
moving between european countries
simple again while staying safe how will
it work exactly
the eu digital covid certificate can be
on your phone or printed out
it will prove that you have been
vaccinated against covid19
that you've had a negative test or that
you've recovered from the infection
it will be in use for the next 12 months
in all member states
the certificate will be subject to
european data protection rules
so your personal health information will
be safe
that sounds expensive how much will it
cost
you don't have to pay for the
certificate plus most eu countries
vaccinate europeans for free
the european parliament also backed
plans to mobilize 100 million euros to
purchase tests needed to obtain the
certificate
can i travel anywhere with the
certificate all eu countries have agreed
to recognize the certificate
in theory that means they should not
impose more restrictions on certificate
holders
unless they are necessary to protect
public health so
check any local restrictions before
traveling